[Music]
legend has it there is a tree in the
Amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers and the Arrowhead is the
key to unlocking it
hello I just wanted you to know this has
been mislabeled
he's shipping outlets
of all the jungle cruisers you can take
in the Amazon
this one is undoubtedly the Chiefs but
also the most thrilling heads-up I'm a
Duke
look out
Marauders
natives ladies and gentlemen the moment
you've all been waiting for
the backside of water stays wonder of
the world
we're headed upriver lagrimas de cristo
mister Huron travel calm about a good
time looking for passage upriver please
go away
I have a lot of money ever you believe
in legends you should believe in curses
- you're gonna bear minutes are back
well I look forward to disappointing you
10,000 to bring you there alive
dead is 15,000 why should I pay more
dead
dead-eyed have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady here we go
[Music]
oh sorry Frank sorry strong form
I cannot swim you put the river cruising
you can't swim the price just went out
[Music]